support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft com / people ready
what's been very interesting through
this period we all read about the
massive collapses or the of the major
firms like AIG or Merrill Lynch merging
into bank of america or lehman brothers
or Bear Stearns and those are all bad
things but what we tend to miss and what
we see through our customer base is just
how dynamic the financial system really
is we have added in the last six months
eighteen hundred new firms as customers
many of those didn't even exist six
months ago many of them are people who
were either laid off from her firm or
decided to leave and do something more
entrepreneurial II setting up shop just
like Mike Bloomberg did by the way 27
years ago when he was fired by Salomon
Brothers a firm that no longer exists in
its current form and that's happening
everywhere and it's not just startups
it's smaller and mid-sized
broker-dealers in the United States and
around the world who weren't so affected
by the credit crisis that we're
experiencing who are seizing the
opportunity to pick up talent that they
couldn't otherwise have been able to
bring on board we're seeing banks around
the world also who were less affected
devising new strategies and moving into
other things so this really is a very
dynamic system that we don't necessarily
recognize we see it with our customers
and that's not going to stop and in fact
if you look back in history see that
it's been the same way every single time
we've been through one of these things
and we've been through probably ten
before
I think that's already happening you
watch the demise of you watch the demise
of Lehman Brothers but what we focus on
a little bit less is the rise of
Barclays right which bought Lehman
Brothers they've now become a New York
giant they're headquartered in New York
and in London but they're in New York
giant and that's part of the dynamism of
the financial system you know Bank of
America isn't in the same form as it was
before neither is Merrill Lynch but you
know bank of america just build a
massive headquarters on bryant park and
now they're going to need probably more
space in New York so I see it as part of
an evolution that is ongoing you know
when Mayor Bloomberg was elected and
asked me to join him back in her early
2002 we step back and we said look we're
a cyclical city at the time New York was
reeling from the bat combo Staz well as
911 both psychologically but also
financially and we said look we've got
to understand the cycles of financial
history so we actually went back and
looked at the previous ten financial
panics bus or crashes and we discovered
remarkable similarities one was that
everybody said the same thing about
every one of them about the future of
New York the future of the financial
system about regulation every single
time and what you saw is New York always
came back the Wall Street model
fundamentally emerged the VAT every time
but the Great Depression relatively
unscathed the regulation was less severe
than people had felt that the depth of
the crisis but most importantly we saw
was the system constantly regenerated
itself and it's in the process of doing
that right now
support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft com / people ready